bonsoir pierre martinet merci d'être
avec nous pourquoi tout d'abord adnane
abou walid el sahraoui était une cible
prioritaire
eh bien il fait partie de toutes les
deux la grande liste des cibles
prioritaires ça fait partie des voies
dire de l'échelon supérieur de ces
groupes islamistes c'était un chef parmi
tant d'autres qui étaient
particulièrement
ciblés depuis plusieurs années il était
particulièrement virulent et sanguinaire
d'après son portrait entre guillemets
donc il est important déjà sur le plan
sur le plan du combat qu'on mène contre
la base de couper les têtes au fur à
mesure qu'on les combats c'est important
de le neutraliser même si faut pas se
leurrer demain il sera remplacé mais il
n'empêche que ça c'est alors ça alors ça
va porter un coup d'arrêt quand même
beaucoup d'arrêts sur le plan militaire
et les coups d'arrêt idéologique parce
qu'il avait senti de son idéologie
particulière et un coup d'arrêt ce moral
bien des vidéos
clairement c'est aussi on imagine une
annonce très politique alors que que la
france dans le même temps annoncé le
retrait du sel après la débâcle aussi en
afghanistan une manière de dire regardez
on part du sel mais on reste efficace et
il faudra surtout compter avec nous au
mali
alors il va y avoir un retrait du mali
progressivement mais il va y avoir une
articulation des forces spéciales sur
les trois pays est concerné niger
burkina faso et du mali
je pense que la lutte contre le contrôle
l'aspect militaire en l'intérieur entre
guillemets d' du projet islamiste
pour moi sera encore de très longue
durée voire sans fin donc on va en
reparler dans 19 ans ou 30 ans
mais on peut pas rester une force une
force conventionnelle ne peut pas rester
au mali encore 10 15 ans pour donner ce
qu'on retrouve qu'on a trop con ce qu'on
voit ce qu'on a vu où je vis en
afghanistan je pense qu'au mali on a
peur que la zone mali malienne
burkina et mallet niger deviennent
l'afghanistan deux africains parce que
si toutes les forces françaises
occidentales parce qu'il ya un peu d'âme
il ya peu d'occident d'occidentaux
là-bas se retire
la nature a horreur du vide il va y
avoir automatiquement des groupes
islamistes qui vont qui vont ils vont
encore plus prendre le pouvoir dans
certaines régions plus se répandre et
dans le même temps la france d'une
certaine manière souhaite aussi faire
cavalier pas seul parce qu'elle a cessé
alliés sur place quoique aujourd'hui on
voit qu'il ya quelques tensions aussi
avec les alliés mais on va on suivait la
ferrière où jean-yves le drian
déclaré absolument incompatibles la
présence notamment du groupe militaire
wagner russe sur place bien que la
russie ait démenti ça veut dire voilà on
est là c'est un message aussi envoyé à
l'argentin malienne
alors les relations avec la jeune
malienne c'est vrai sont sont tendues en
revanche pour avoir fait déjà des débats
sur ce sujet sur votre plateau je crois
le cnt malien ne peut pas forcément que
l'ensemble de la de la force par yann se
retire ce ils veulent qui est qu'elle
soit moins visibles et qui aimeraient
articulations
de 7,2 cette force au mali pour que la
population malienne ne se sent pas entre
guillemets occupé par par la france donc
c'est un petit peu ça qu'il faut qu'il
faut
adoucira rendirent l'exemple
effectivement il ne faudrait pas que le
mali deviennent aussi la centrafrique
parce que je vous dis propos pour info
la flandre à la centrafrique
c'est le groupe wagner qui a qui est
entre guillemets au pouvoir et
les centrafricains aujourd'hui
commencent à déchanter de la présence de
ce groupe là en chez eux parce que c'est
ils se servent sur la bête commun
comment on peut commander chez nous et
ils sont aux manettes de beaucoup
d'entreprises là-bas et
la centrafrique commence à petit peut
être toutes les touches et les wagner
donc je pense que wagner c'est pas une
bonne idée au mali
quel impact pourrait avoir la
disparition en tout cas de de ce chef
vous dites il va quoi qu'il arrive être
remplacé et il y aura t'il quand même un
bénéfice à court terme
un bénéfice à très court terme bénéfices
sur moi et déjà passé parce que il a été
il a été drone est entre guillemets il
ya déjà quelques quelques jours donc il
est peut-être sur le point d'être
remplacé mais c'est quand même c'est
quand même un marqueur c'est quand même
un impact psychologique sur ces groupes
islamistes ça veut dire qu'on peut les
maintenant ce qui est intéressant dans
cette élimination c'est qu'on peut dire
que c'est une opération aux mots
pourquoi parceque il a été localisé par
a priori d'après ce que j'ai pu lire il
a été localisé par via son téléphone par
des américains et les français l'ont
frappé avec un drone donc les français
disposent aujourd'hui j'ai pas de 1 ou 2
drones armés ces nouveautés
on entend pas tellement mais aujourd'hui
les français sont capables de frapper
des des djihadistes à distance mais
ensuite ils ont envoyé des forces pour
pour pour confirmer cette la cible mais
c'est assez nouveau parce qu'il ya un
décalage quand même avec ce qu'on entend
en france c'est un parallèle que je fais
à chaque fois mais là bas au mali on les
capture pas pour les juger on les tue
sans jugement alors qu'en france vous
avez vu tous les djihadistes on est on
est on essaie de les capturer pour les
juges il ya un vrai décalage entre dans
cette bière qui est globale il faut pas
dissocier ce qui se passe en europe et
ce qui se passe en afrique pour moi
c'est exactement la même chose et c'est
pour ça qu'on est quand même le entre le
marteau et l'enclume parce qu'on
n'arrive pas en france a
repoussé ces djihadistes de façon
idéologique donc on est coincé je pense
avec nos droits de l'homme et notre
justice qui est bien ou pas bien ça
c'est chacun se fera son idée mais il ya
une nouveauté aujourd'hui c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on est en droit de les
les djihadistes en a pris qui ça je
trouve que c'est pas mal parce que ça
évite des pertes chez nous merci pierre
martinet d'avoir apporté votre analyse
en direct sur rt france